よろしくお願いします
この無知という言葉について
あるいは鈍感という言葉について
瞑想を 頑張っている方々から よく聞かれる質問です
だいたい瞑想を実践する方々は
自分の妄想というか
思考を確認するときは
いとも簡単に 怒りなどは発見できるのですね
これは怒りだと
それから欲も発見できるのですね
これは欲ですよと
そこで貪瞋痴の痴って何なのかと
これはどうやって確認すれば よろしいかという
よく聞かれる質問ですね
それに何回も まとめて答えたことはありますけど
見事に理解してくれない ということもあります
それぐらい ややこしいことですね
無知というのは
ですから
今日は 少し その無知について 考えてみましょう
今日は 雨が降ってないのですけどね
まだまだ 雨季ですけどね
もし 私たちが 外に行ったら
ほんのわずかの雨の粒が 体に触れる 落ちてきて
またもう一つ 時間経ったら もう一つ粒が触れる時もありますね
我々は 全然 雨だと言わないのですね その時は
まあ 霧雨とも言うのですが
そんな大胆なことじゃく もっと薄い
ほんの少しの水の 見えないほどの一滴が 体に触れてもわからないのです
雨でしょう？
いえいえ 雨ではない
大丈夫ですよ と平気で言うのです
雨でありません
そこで　その小さなものが どんどん回数が増えていくのです
それで どんどん粒も 大きくなってくるのです
その時は 手やら 肩やら 頭やら
あちこちにもう水が
ものすごく大きな水の
一滴 一滴が
体に ポツンポツンと落ちると
雨ですよ 傘をささなければ ということになるのですね
それは我々誰にもある経験
私も同じことです
よっぽど体濡れるぐらい 水が落ちてこないならば
そのまま 走っちゃうのです
傘 さそうとは思わない
ちょっと霧雨のような感じだったら
空の状況で
まあこれぐらいだったら大丈夫だと
傘を持っていかないぞと
ということにもなるのですね
私の場合だと
まあとにかく その例というのは どなたでもわかっていること
ほんのちょっと 一滴の水が 体に落ちただけで 雨とは言わない
その例をなぜ申し上げたかというと
我々にとって雨ですよという理解
雨ですよという認識を作るために
大量に 水がかぶってこないと わからないということなのです
かなりの量の水が上から来て
かぶって 濡れてない限りは 雨だとは認識しません
誰でも そこは事実です
そこで そっと静かに耳を澄まして
聞いてください
いろいろ聞こえるでしょう
もっともっと静かに聞いていると
もっと音が聞こえるのです
そこでもっと完璧な遮断した所で
音を遮断した所で
全く音が外から入らない所で 静かに座ってみてください
何も聞こえないと思いますか？
ものすごく音が聞こえるのです
体の中の音
いろいろ聞こえます
脳の中でも いろいろ信号を送るときは 結構コンピューターと同じく
キーキーという音を出しているのです
しかし我々には今聞こえない
今聞こえるのは私の声だけかもしれません
時々大きな音を出して騒音を出して
車とか何かが通ったら
それは聞こえる
あのわずかな音は聞こえないのです
それで年取ってくると
どんどん耳が遠くなって 鈍感になってくるのですね
いわゆる外の音が 聞こえなくなってくるのですね
その時　大体の人々が言う 一つの文句があります
よく耳鳴りがする
そこで本人が なんか少し 調子が良くないとかね
これは調べてもらわなくてはいけないとかね
耳鳴りなんかするとね
いろんな他の病気の 前兆でもありますと
脳出血とかね
そういう前兆でもありますとかね
怖くなったりもします
実は 小さい時から 耳鳴りはしています
ある日 突然ということではないのです
ただ　年とともに 外の音にある感受性が
どんどん衰えますから 細胞がね
受け取れなくなります
雷ぐらいの音でなければ 聞こえなくなります
そうすると
この体の中の音が 聞こえ始めて
それは止まることなく 聞こえるのですからね
それが耳鳴りとか 何とか言ってるのです
ですから 実は 外の音に 少し鈍感になったという
衰えたというぐらいのことです
それで私は何を 申し上げたいというと
我々は 本当は ずっと 大量の音を 受け取ってはいるのですが
認識はしていない
音は受け取ってはいますが
認識はしてありません
ですから 小さなこの水の1滴の 10分の1ぐらいの小さな水の
素粒子ぐらいの少しだけ
あちこち 体に触れても 全然気が付かない
雨が降っていると
それも結局は雨なのです
山の上とかね
いっぱい 霧に隠れている時とかね
この霧の中とか 歩いてみてください
まあ霧だけですよと 平気で歩くでしょうね
15～30分ぐらい経つと 全部濡れてるのです
雨ですよ
ですからこの雨なのですが
雨だと認識しない
そういうふうに 目の場合も 同じなのです
例えば目のケースは
私が何か皆様に見せて
カチンと見せてさっと閉めちゃう
見えますかね
その場合は
見えません
例えば この白板に 何か私は 隠して文字を一つ書いて
それから この紙で隠して 文字を書いて
サッと見せてまた閉めちゃう
見えるのでしょうかね
見えないのです
皆さんはよく知ってる
カメラありますよ
カメラというのは 大体 かなりのスピードで シャッターが閉まるのですね
大体まあ
1 秒の 400分の1とかね
一般的には それぐらいの スピードで カメラのシャッターが 閉まるのです
そうでなければ 我々は 手がブレるのだから いい写真撮れないのです
それで 1秒の 10分の1とかね
1 秒の60分の1に なってしまうと
我々は当然三脚を使うのです
カメラの場合は
でないと 写真がもう ブレちゃうというかね
そこで私たちの目では
1 秒の 400分の1 というのは まるっきり見えないのです
なのに きちんと あの映像が フィルムには 記録しているのです
私はこの子供二人いるしね
子供の頃やった実験ですけど
カメラを開けて レンズをつけるところを開けて
これは何者かと ずっと シャッターを 押してみるのですね
見えません
レンズから 外の光は 一応 見えるはずということは知ってます
それで カメラの後ろの蓋を開けて
目を合わせて シャッターを押してみたのですけど
押しても なんか動くのだけど見えません
それで一番スローモーションにして
一番スローというのは シャッターを押して 指で外さない限りは 開けっぱなしで
その時はなんとか見える
まあ　一応
60分の1とか
40分の1に してしまうと 見えるのですね
光が入ったと
ですから我々の目でも大体
1 秒の半分ぐらいでも 光入らないと 見えないのですね
耳も同じで
目も同じで 鼻も同じですよ
今 この空間で 香りがないと思いますか？
確実にあります
しかし これ大量に ぶつけてこないと感じないだけ
ものすごい 大量に 匂いが 鼻に入って
ひどく攻撃すると
ああ　変な匂いとか言うのです
でなければわからないのですね
だって犬などはもう人間より
1万分の1の 小さな匂いでも 嗅げちゃうのです
例えば この紙は どんな匂いか
私が 嗅いでみたって 全然わからない
しかし　それなりの訓練して 犬にこれ 嗅いでもらってください
もらったら すぐ 私が捕まりますからね
この人やと
ですから
我々の鼻も 大量の匂いが 入り込まない限りは
匂いということは 認識しない
味の場合も同じことでね
私は よく みんなが ご飯食べると 見ますけどね
醤油を バンバンかけるわ
時々 若い者などは ご飯にも 塩をかける
見ていられなくなってしまうのですね
塩を食べている状態でも
それぐらい
0.1～0.5gぐらい 塩がなければ ご飯の味を感じないと
お醤油 いっぱいかけないと
食べ物の味が わからないということも 我々に普通にあることで
私が一つ これを言いたいのです
今も舌は味を感じているのです
では唾液の
味を知ってますか？
舌　自分でも味を持ってるのです
ちょっと試しに感じてみてください
味 持ってます
しかし普通は全然感じません
ですから味に鈍感な人だったら
かなり強烈に 食べ物に 味をつけておかないと 美味しいとは言わない
体の場合も同じです
ものすごい激しく 何か触れない限りは わからないのです
微妙に 例えば 毛の先で ほんのちょっと触れただけで 全然わからないのです
髪の毛の先ぐらいで
ちょっと体を ちょっとこうやって 削ってみると
ちょっと触れてみると
全然わかりません
しかし 指でこうやって さしてしまうとわかるのです
指でもかすかに何か触れる
触れないぐらいに してみるとわからないのですね
そういうことで
体にしても
大量に 爆弾みたいな データが ぶつからないと 認識しないのです
そこがどんな人間にもある問題です
なぜそんなこと関係ありますかね
今日の話に
ですから簡単に結論を言えば
だから 鈍感でしょう
鈍感です
それだけの 結論です
ですから 普通は 我々は 気づくと もう手遅れ
もっと大げさに言うならば
雨ですよ と気づくと もう濡れているのです
ですから他の例に入れ替えてみると
例えば 家の中で どこでも かすかにでも 火とかなんとかあると
それに 気づくのだったら 火事にはなりません
そこでグーグーと寝ていて
家が半分ぐらい焼けて
ものすごい 音を立てて 熱くていられなくなったところで 目を覚ましてみたら
ああ　火事ですよ
もう手遅れですけど
ですから
大体は 人類が 何かに気づくと もう手遅れ
例えば 今 自然を破壊している とおっしゃっているのですね
気づいたね 自然を破壊していると
もう手遅れですけど
ですからそこら辺が問題なのです
気づくと手遅れになっている
自分の体が 病気だと 気づくと もう手遅れです
もうどうにもならん
私も 肩が 随分痛いのですけど
医者に聞いてみれば
これもかなり前からね
関節とかね
よく動かしておかないと
毎日 毎日 どんどん硬くなってくるのだよと
それで 私が気づくと もう治療不可能ぐらい もう手遅れですね
ですから 気づく前に きちんと 手を動かしたり
いろいろ運動したり しておいたならば
関節はきちんと動いてくれます
ある日突然
あら 手が随分痛いのではないかと 気づいたところで
もうかなり 重症というかね
もう悪化して もうかなりのところまで 進んでいるのですね
ですから がんですよと気づくと
大体は まあ進行は 中ぐらいには いってるのですね
初期段階でね
気づいていければ
いとも簡単に 治るものですからね
がんというのは 治療も 何もないのですからね
それ取っちゃえば いいのですから
しかし 気づくと 手遅れですね
ですから
我々は 人間にとっては がんというのは 大変な病気だ と今思ってはいるのですね
そういうことで理解してほしいのは
我々の認識の問題
鈍感ですよ
ですから 仏教で 無知という話だから
かなり今日馬鹿にされるだろうかなとか
もうそういう誤解する必要ないよ
誰も馬鹿にしてるわけではないのです
ただ事実を語ってるだけですね
ですから
この無知と言っても
これは私ではないのですよと 他の人やということは
ちょっと成り立たないのですね
お釈迦様の教えは いつでも
みんなそうですけど という態度では聞けないのです
そうです お釈迦様おっしゃる通りです
みんなそうです ということを言われれば
お釈迦様にすごい叱られます
いえ 違います あなたですよと
という態度で説法するのです
だって 意味がないのです
例えばお釈迦様がね
みんな 怒りで 憎しみで 多大な損 自分にもするし
他人にも与えますよ と言われたところで
そうですね まあ そういう人々もいますよと 言われたところで
お釈迦様に 何も意味のない説法でしょう
そこで お釈迦様はそうではありません あなたが怒りを抑えなさいと
あなたのことを言っているのだよ
まあ　そういうことだから
一応どんな人間でも
そういう 鈍感というところが あるのですね
これはどうにもならないこと
例えば 一回目を開けて 閉めただけで物は見えません
例えば この紙をこうやって見せただけで 見えますかね
これを読みたれば
じーっと時間をかけて こういうふうに 読まなければいけない
いわゆる大量のデータが入らないと わからないということ
そこで このお醤油でも いいのですけど
よく 家庭には 針がありますね
安全ピンや いろいろ針という
英語で ピンと言うのですけど
日本語で何というかわかりません
まあ針で お醤油に針を入れて
そこでつけますよ
針に お醤油をちゃんと
その針の先に 見えないぐらい
大きな一滴ではない
針の先ですからね
毛が一番いい例 ですけどね
毛って 少し気持ち悪くなるかも しれませんからね
この針ちょっと刺して 醤油の中に
自分の舌に入れてみる
わかりますかね
わからないのですね
そこで かなりの量を取って 舌に入れてみると
この醤油は どんな味かと
辛口か 薄口か 何なのかと わかるのですね
ということは
針の先から 醤油を舐めてみても
我々にとっては 無意味で 意味は 持たないのです
これ　日本語で どういうふうに 言えばいいかわかりませんけど
私は 英語で 自分勝手に 決めた言葉ですけど
Sensible（センシブル）という
別に英語でも sensible（センシブル）でも ないのですけど
まあ一応 そういう言葉だったら 意味は通じるのではないかなと
このセンシブルデータ
いわゆる感じられる 意味を持つという意味で
それで 針先から 醤油を舌に触れても 意味は持たないのですね
データが入ったのですが
そのデータが センシブルデータではありません
いわゆる 意味を持つデータではないのです
そこで小指でも 醤油の中に入れて 小指を舐めてみると
ああ　まあこれは醤油ですよ とすぐわかるのです
ですから 大量のデータが入らないと
センシブルという 意味を持つということは 成り立たない
無意味になる
ですから
我々はそれをないことにする
知らないのですから
認識できてないのですから
なかったことにする
ですから今
空気の香りは 無臭ですね
香りないことにしています
自分の手などはね
そうやって嗅いでみて
うん　まあ無臭ですよと
私たちはないことにしても
犬に聞いてみれば もう激しい匂いするのです
その区別を よく理解してほしいのです
すごい大事なポイントを 説明したいのですから
まあかなりこの
回り道を 私はとってますけど
ですから私はまあ 随分焦って設定したのだから
英語でしか 頭の中で できてないのです
まだまだシステムが
とにかく センシティブデータということで
日本語だったら 閾値って言う
閾値って 値が 感じられる範囲の上か下かという そういう境目を
ああ　なるほど
閾値
まあ　この場合
私は データの量のことを 一応考えて
例えば 音の場合は 聞こえる音
聞こえない音が ありますね
その範囲の中で 犬に聞こえる音があって
人間に聞こえない とかね
その問題では ないのです
本当は聞こえる音ですが
たくさん量が入らないと 聞こえないということ
そうすると少し違うかもしれない
例えば 光の場合は 赤外線は見えないのは当たり前で
紫外線も見えないのは当たり前
そうではなくて
視界に入る光線ですけど
たくさん入らなければ 見えませんと
大量 にボーンと 光が目にぶつからないと 見えないということ
その量の問題ですね
ですからセンシビリティというのは そこで成り立つのですね
ですから visible audibleとか
聞こえる 見えるとか
英語の単語あるけど それは合わないのです
センシブル 感じることはできるか
いわゆる 感知可能な量
俗っぽい話で考えましょう
自分のポケットから
1円とかね
10円とか 落っこっちゃったとします
道路の中にある 大きな穴がありますね 下水道の
落ちた後 転がっちゃって
その中に行っちゃうのですね
あ お金がなくなった どうしようか と思いますかね
全然 あ 落っこっちゃった
それで終わっちゃうのです
ですから 損したということは それでは感じません
そこで 自分の財布が 丸ごとなくなる
その時は やっぱり お金がなくなった
どうしようかと 感じるのですよ
ですから どんなものにも お金がなくなったということを 感じるためにも
ある量がないと
例えば 料理など作っている間は 味見たりするでしょうね
ちゃんと料理は そのまま食べてますけどね
スープを作って
小さじ1杯くらいは飲んでみて
まあこれで大丈夫だとかね
していますけど
あんた ご飯食べたのでしょうか？と聞かれて
食べてないと言うでしょう
あれ　ご飯食べたというためには
それなりの 量が必要です
例えばご飯1粒食べてみます
どうですか？
味とかね
あんたご飯食べたでしょう？
って言うと
冗談ではない 食べてないのだよ と言うのです
それで 茶碗で ご飯半分でも 取って食べたならば
やっぱり ご飯食べましたと 言っちゃうのですね
ですから １粒のご飯食べて ご飯食べたと言わない
ですから最低限で何粒食べれば ご飯食べたと言うのでしょうかと
そこら辺は 量の問題ですね
決められませんけどね
しかしあります確実に
あるでしょう その事実は
ですから
例えばお金がなくなったというためには
10円ですか 50円ですか
1,000円ですかと決められません
子供など
50円なくなっただけでも びっくりして
もう混乱して もう泣き叫んじゃいますし
大人は たった50円でしょうということで
お金なくなったと いうことにしないのですね
その認識はしない
それで 若者 は自分持っている 全部お金財布に入れて 出かけたところで
財布がなくなってしまうと
お金が全部なくなったと
ものすごいショックを受けちゃう
大人が すべて家にある全財産を 財布に入れるのではなくて
その用事に必要なものだけ 財布に入れて出て行ったところで
財布がなくなってしまうと
全財産がなくなったという ショックはないのです
ですから
この量も それぞれ 随分複雑で
数字的には言えませんけど
事実では はっきりあります
そこまで理解できますかね
このポイントは
あるセンシティブデータの量 というのはあるのだと
いわゆる認識可能なというか
認識する量というのは
「そしたら感度ではないですか？」
まあ感度だけでは足らないのですね
Sensible（センシブル）といえば 感度という意味ですけどね
感度…。何でしょうかね？
まあ一応 私は感覚認識という 言葉は 日本語としては 使いたいのですね
これは結局 認識の問題ですからね
赤いと認識する
青いと認識する
しかし 大量の赤が 目に入らなければ 赤いとは認識しない
針の先で 赤が塗ってあっても
先っぽで誰もわからない
しかし それを顕微鏡で 大きくしてしまうと
赤いと認識します
ですから 顕微鏡で このデータの量を 増やしてしまうのですね
ですから英語で magnifyと呼ぶのです
拡大ですからね
顕微鏡というのは拡大鏡でしょう
拡大しなければ認識できません
それは すべての認識についてある問題
どれぐらい量が必要でしょうか
そこで 次に私はこのSensible（センシブル）という 認識可能という段階に入りたいのです
認識って何なのかと
そこで我々は知っている世界
私は歴史勉強しているのだ
医学勉強しているのだ
法律を勉強しているのだとか
よく知ってる世界あるでしょう
我々は 何々会社の仕事をしているのだとか
私は女性だ
男性だとかね
我々は大量の認識を持っているのです
大量の概念を持っているのです
大量の知識を持っているのです
その知識は正しいと思っているのです
自分が知っていることですから
正しいのは当たり前だと
例えば 法律家に向かって 私が何かうるさいことを言うと
法律家が怒るのですね
「あんた 法律も何も知らないで うるさいことを言うなよ」と
「私は法律家ですから知ってますよ」と
ですから
法律に 私みたいに法律のABC も知らない人が 何か言っても否定されちゃうのですね
自分の知識は正しいと思うのですね
そういうふうに誰でも自分の知識が正しいと思っているのです
自分の知っていることは正しい
自分の見たものは見たのだから正しい
「私は聞いたのだから正しいと」と思っちゃうのですね
そこからですね　問題は
それであなたは知っているのはいいのだけど
あなたは大量のデータが入らなければ知らないでしょうと
ですから我々の認識の世界というのは
もう爆弾爆発するみたいに大量のデータがバンバン入ったところで知ったものなのです
１粒の水の素粒子ぐらい小さな水の
１滴で雨と決めたのではなくて
それなりに大量に水が体にかかったところで雨と認識するのですからね
「雨が降ってますよ」と
「私は濡れちゃったんだから知ってますよ」
「正しいのだよ」というようになるのです
ですから
これを理解してください
我々の知識というのは
その各人が持っているこのSensible（センシブル）という認識の量によって決めちゃうのですね
本当に申し訳ないのですけど
英語の単語しか思い浮かばないのですね
英語で言えばdepends on the level of sensitivity
sensitivityのレベルによります
ですから　人間の中で知識の差というのは当然出てきます
当たり前で出てくるのです
100円なくなったところでびっくりする人もいるし
1万円札なくなったのだけど
全く気にしない人もいるし
ですからお金がなくなったと認識するためにも
人間平等ではありません
ですから
料理にみんなそれぞれ各自で塩をかけたり
胡椒をかけたりするのです
例えば料理作る人が味をつけて
あ　これで料理ですよと 作って食卓に持ってきても
食べる人々は自分自分でまた
味を調整しますでしょう
ですから
私がこれが美味しいと決めても
他の人は美味しいとは決めないのですね
なので私は何か食べ物を持ったら
「まあ これは もう十分塩味がありますよ」と言っても
他の人は「やっぱり塩を少し入れましょう」と
簡単な例というのは
寿司とかね
私 そのまま食べるのです
同じものを皆様で 一緒に食べると
強引に私にお醤油を入れてくれるのですね
お醤油をかけてくださいと
親切な行為ですけど
ちょっと大きいのですね
私にとっては
醤油に触れちゃうと
もうしょっぱくて 塩味でね
なんか気持ち悪くなってしまう
すごい辛くて
それは 個人の差で
ですから　そうやってある人の味の感覚の量と
また もう一人の人の味の感覚の量って
それぞれに変わっちゃうのです
私の場合は塩味よりも
私は海苔を巻いてる
その味を味わいたいのですね
醤油の味ではなくて
ですから入っちゃうとえらい邪魔
全部元の味を 消しちゃいますからね
どうしても食べなさいというならば食べますけど
でもその時は詰め込むという理屈でいくのです
もう食べるのではなくて
では詰め込みましょうと
お金がなくなったという場合でも
美味しいという場合でも
綺麗という場合でも
汚いという場合でも
いろんな判断の場合は
我々は この認識の可能な量で物事を決まっているのですね
それで私は一番先にそれが鈍感だと言ったでしょう
鈍感ですよ
認識するともう手遅れですよ
ということで
私たちには この眼耳鼻舌身から入る情報について 正しい知識がないのです
その結論わかりますかね?
目で見た 故に知っているということは言えないはずです
目に大量なものが入ったら知ったのであって
その量も各人によって違う
例えば耳の感度の量によって
この部屋はうるさい
静かとか
いろんな人がいろんな意見を出すのですね
この部屋はうるさいという人は
自分が正しいと思ってこちらに喧嘩売ってきても
静かやと思って
何か誰か音楽でもかけてくれないかというふうに怒ってきても
どちらでも当てにならないのです
それはその各人の主観的な問題で
感受性の問題です
そこで初めて主観という言葉が成り立つのです
このセンシビリティから主観というのが成り立つのですね
ですから おにぎり美味しいですよ と言っても
主観ですよ その人の
二人がおにぎり美味しいですよと言っても
二人が別々な感受性の量を持ってますからね
別々な認識でしゃべっているのです
ですから 永久的に 我々は主観主義者達で
共感性というのはないのです
みんなと一緒に分かち合うことはないのです
成り立たないのです
自分だけの世界の中にいるのです
それはこのお釈迦様の教えで 厳密にこの...。
ちょっとアビダンマ的みたい
アビダンマはこんなにわかりやすくは言ってないのですけど
自分勝手にわかりやすくと言ってもね
それもまた主観ですけど(笑)
自分にとってはね
明確に分析しているつもりです
その 主観という問題が出てきて
それでどんな人でも 自分の殻の中に いるようになってしまっちゃうのですね
その機能に 仏教は無知というのです
今まで説明した 心理学的な機能がありますね
このセンシビリティという問題について
感受性について
それに 無知と言うのですよ
無明と言うのです
そういうわけで
無知無明がない人が あり得るのですかね?
動物でも 誰でも ありえないのです
神々でも 誰でも ありえないです
一切の生命は 衆生が 無知です
犬は人間より嗅覚が鋭いと言っても
犬にもわからない匂いがありますよ
犬でも匂いはね  1万分の1とか
人間の感受性からね
1万分の1ぐらいに減っちゃうと 大体わからないのです
やっぱりそれぐらいなければ
音にすごく敏感な動物達もいますけどね
ヘビとかはね
耳はあるのだけど
感受性というのは随分鈍い
試しに大きい声出してヘビを起こしてみてください
起きません
耳といっても耳たぶはないのだけどね
耳の奥の鼓膜が 外にありますけれども
それを触るとわかりますけど
それでカエルの場合も カエルの耳がありますね
ですから人間の耳の奥の鼓膜を触っちゃうと
我々にとっては痛くてたまらないのです
例えば綿棒でも
その鼓膜のところでゴソゴソとやると
ものすごい音がするでしょう
少しでも早くしてしまうと
もう痛くて痛くて
しかしカエルの場合は触れますよ
すごく鈍感です
しかし カエルの場合は
カエルにも すごい音だったら聞こえると思います
カエルの声を聞いたことはございますね
かなりすごい音ですね
あれぐらい拡大して鳴かないと
カエル同士では わからないのです
そこでカエルなど捕まえて
カエルの耳を指で触ってみてください
別に 何のことないね
カエルは平気でいるのです
しかし音は聞こえますから
その場合は目がね 下に沈んじゃうのです
うるさいと
私はそれがあまりにも可愛くてね
カエルを捕まえたら触ってみるのです
触ったら飛び出してる目がジュッと中に入っちゃう
そういうことで
カエルにしても 犬にしても
動物にしても
ある量のデータが入らないとわからないということ
いわゆる鈍感ということがあるのです
鈍感の度合いは各生命によって違う
ですから
幽霊の鈍感さと 人間の鈍感さが違うでしょうし
神々の鈍感さと 我々の鈍感さがいろいろ違うかもしれませんしね
だからといって機能は同じです
あまりにも専門的な話では
難しくなるかもしれませんが
私が持っていきたいポイントというのは
このセンシビリティということで
我々は世の中を知ってるのだぞと言っても
これ自体が当てにならない
まず大量のデータが入らないとわからない
それで感じたものについて次に判断する
それまた当てにならないでしょう
その場合は
いろんなセンシビリティの世界で 感じる世界の差が出てくるのです
例えば 1番目は
人間だけに言っちゃうと
人間誰でも一般的に感じること
例えばお腹が空いたとかね
眠いとか 痛いとか 暑いとかね
一応 どんな人間も感じる
では それで暑いということは
私も感じる
皆さんも感じる
どんな人間も感じます
寒いということも感じます
では それで我々に共感性ありますか？
ないのですよ
だって 日本の方々が暑いということと
エジプトの方々が暑いということは違いますからね
随分違います
エジプトやエチオピアではね
昼間になると毎日
40度に軽々いきます
その人は 毎日暑い暑いと言ってますかね
普通ですからね
私たちにとっては 40度というのは
ちょっと想像できない お風呂の状態ですから
私も 40度の風呂には全く入れません
ですから
暑いということも みんな共通のように見えるのだけど
結局は共通ではないのです
例えば 物を見て白いですよと
誰でも白い
そうでもない
白いという色についても
それぞれの人間が いろいろ思っています
例えばお腹が空いたんだということは
生命　みんなのお腹が空くでしょう
日本人のお腹も空くし
アフリカ人のお腹も空くし
西洋人のお腹も空きますけど
でもお腹が空いたというところでも
それぞれの人の考え方はまた違うのです
時々 1 日1回しか食べられない人々もいます
1 日 1回しか食べられない人が
今日 1 日食べたならば
今日 1 日お腹が空いたと言いますかね
言わないのです
感じ方は変わるのです
テレビで見たのですけど
アフリカの方ですけど
ものすごく元気な ものすごく健康な体格の人でしたけど
一回しか食べないとか何とかでしょうね
しょっちゅうは食べません
すごく元気ですけど
そこで その人は日本にいるのだから
1日3回でも 4回でも食べられるでしょう
日本でも食べません
一回しか
ですから その人と日本人が友達になっても
友達の日本人が
1日3回、4回ぐらい お腹が空いたと言うし
あの人は何も言わないし
今日お腹が空いたと言うのは１回で
また明日になってお腹が空いた 何か食べようということになるのですね
ですから
お腹が空いたという感じさえも
今 例に出したアフリカの方が
1 日1回言うことで
しかし日本人だったら
1日3回、4回ぐらいのものになってしまうのですね
ですからやっぱり残念なことに 共通性がなくなってしまうのですね
客観性ってのは
それ一つ
共通
みんなに同じ主観についても そんな問題なのです
それから
各民族によって
各人類によって
また感じ方が違う
例えば美しいと感じることは
人類は同じく感じるはずでしょう
みんな同じ生物学的にホモサピエンスですから
美しいということは
チンパンジーだったら
チンパンジーのメスがすごく美人だと思っているでしょうね
人間の女性見て
「あ　美人だ」とか
「追っかけましょう」とかね
あれ　何といいますか
男たちやること
話しかけることはなんとか言うでしょう
女性に なんて言いますか
みんなやってるでしょう
道路で女の人を見たら
なんかちょっと話をかけて
え？誘惑ではない
え？ナンパ
例えば 言いたかったのは
チンパンジーは決して人間の女性をナンパしません
チンパンジーのメスだったら ナンパしようとする
だから美しいということは
それぞれの生命によって違うのですね
それで我々みんな人間ですから
では同じことに美しいと感じるかというと
そこでまた差が出てきて
日本の美と 西洋の美というのは違う
インド人の美感覚 また違う
インド人が綺麗という話と 日本人が綺麗という話が ずいぶん違う
どこかの国では
女性というのは 体がドラム缶みたいに
丸々太っていないと 美人では受け取れない
ですからみんなものすごく体格が大きい
女性たちが
男たちは普通
それで結構 人気ありますね
それで日本の人々に聞いたら
全く反対の考え方ですね
骸骨でなければ 美人ではないと
ですから そこの感覚が違うのですね
そこで南アジアというか
南インドとかね
そこら辺に行くと
女性はよくアクセサリーつけるのですね
それで耳から 耳の下と上で
もうこちらで こちらも こちらも
もうここからここまでとかね
もうアクセサリーばっかりで
ですからその場合は いっぱいつけた方が 金属をね
ほとんど金とか銀とかですけどね
体に金属を量たくさんつければ美しいと
しかしあれほどは 決して いくらお金あっても日本の女性はつけません
特別なことでつけるかもしれませんが
そうでなければ 付けませんね
ですから美しく見せるということで
アクセサリーつける場合でも
それぞれ認識が違うのです
それで文化的に民族的な差というのは
日本人はご飯美味しいというし
西洋人はパン美味しいというし
我々インド文化系はご飯だったらカレー
カレーの文化だよと思っちゃうし
こちらは醤油文化だよと思っちゃう
そうやっていろいろ民族的に差が出てくる
年代的にも差が出てくる
子供にとって美しいものは
大人にとっては面白くないのですね
大人が綺麗と言うものには 子供は綺麗とは思わない
そうやって
そこの中でも 差が出てくるのです
それから 我々はいろいろ勉強したりしますね
いろんなことを勉強したり
考えたり
研究したりします
それで知識が増えるのです
それでもって センシビリティのレベルがまた変わっちゃうのです
例えば同じ絵を見ても
絵のことを勉強している人の感受性と 全く知らない人の感受性違うでしょう
同じ曲を 音楽家が聞く 普通の人が聞く
二人の受け方が違うのです
そういうのは大体一般的な知識ですから おわかりになると思いますけど
そこで子供もなんとかね
息を吸ったり吐いたりして歌ってるでしょう
子供の場合は 息を吐きながら歌って
また 吸いながらも歌いますからね
大人みたいにちゃんと息を吐いて
それで歌って
次また息を吸って歌う ということはないのです
それは子供の歌い方ですけどね
その場合も 子供が変な歌い方ですけど
音声とか 何もないしね
それでも親が子供が歌ってくれると すごく喜んじゃうのですね
ああ 上手に歌えたと 拍手までおくるとかね
同じく他人の子供が歌っても
もう うるさいって感じに なるのではないですかね
ですから
そうやって感受性というのは変わるものです
それは知識の問題で
だから知識ある人と 知識ない人の感受性も また変わる
何かについて研究した人の知識と
研究していない人の知識が変わる
ですから
我々のこのセンシブルという私が書いた言葉
センシビリティー
感受性で理解してみましょう
この感受性というものは
勉強によっても
研究によっても
思考によってもまた 変わってしまっちゃうのですね
それからくだない 妄想をするでしょう
あれやこれやとかね
私はあまりいい人間ではないのだとかね
不幸な人間だとかね
別に証拠があるわけではないけど
ほとんど妄想する場合は
いい加減に同じことをずっと妄想してしまうのですね
私のことをみんな嫌っているとかね
そうやって妄想してしまうと
その本人に見える世界は また変わっていくのです
私のことみんな気になってるのだと思って
そういう妄想を持っていっちゃうと
世の中に生きてると いつでもその人に見える世界が 変わっていくのです
例えば精神的な病気になった人が
「私のことをみんなが批判しているのだ」と
その妄想を働かせてしまうと
人が何をしゃべろうが関係なく
「あの人は私のことを批判しているのだよ」と
そうすると私たちが「あなた何言ってるのですか？」と
「その人にとってはあなたのことは関係ないのだよ」と言うのです
そうすると
その人の反応は「あなたは鈍感だからわからないだけでしょう」と
「私はよくわかっているのだよ」
と言うのです
「確かにあの人は私の悪口言ってるのだ」と
それはこの妄想やら幻覚やら作っちゃうと
さらにこの感受性が変わってしまっちゃうのです
ですから 本人が「自分が知った世界が正しい」と思っています
どうにもならない
大変なことです これは
それだけではなくて 5番目もあります
私はこのセンシビリティーということは いろんな条件で変わりますよということを
今 説明して 4つ言いましたけど
5番目:いろんなことを信じる 信仰する
例えば 確かに神様がいると信仰してみてください
全て その目で見えるのです
全て その目線で見える
例えば 不思議な動物を見ると
「神様が よくぞ そういう風に考えてお作りになったのですね」とかね
例えば カンガルーいますね
カンガルーの赤ちゃんというのは
1ｃｍぐらいの長さで ものすごく小さい
4分の１に切った ミミズぐらいの大きさですね
お腹の中が小さいし 生殖器官も全部 相当小さいのですから
小さいウジ虫ぐらいの 小さなカンガルーが生まれてくるのです
アリにさえ 食べられちゃいますよ
それで不思議なことは
その小さなカンガルーの赤ちゃんには 産まれてすぐに
「お腹の上へ登る」という記録を 遺伝子に書きこまれているのですね
ですから なんとか登って 袋がありますね
その袋の中に入り込むのです
袋の中に子供がいても
カンガルーのお母さんだとは 全くわかっていません
その中で長い間おっぱいを飲んで大きくなるのです
そこで 「全て神様が作ったのだ」と思っちゃう人にとっては
「なんて不思議でしょうかね」
そういうふうに有袋というのですかあれは sackはね
「そういうふうに 有袋すると
その中でおっぱい作ってあげなかったら
カンガルーの赤ちゃんが死ぬのではないか」と
「うまくできてるものだな」とか
「さすが神様でなければ そんなことは設計することは無理」と
言って　その人にとっては
カンガルーの例にしても 神様がいるということの証拠になる
ですから
いろいろな「信仰」
それから「固定概念」
それから「マインドコントロール」
なども我々の知識を左右するのです
認識を左右させちゃうのです
例えば 神様を信じない 私たちにとっては
いろいろな生命の生き方というのは
その環境に合わせてできていることで
おなかの中で子どもを育てられない場合は
卵にして産んで逃げちゃうとかね
それで卵の中から出てくると　1人前　そういうものもいるし
ずっとつきっきりで面倒を見なければいけない生命もいるし
それなりに我々の生活は変わっているのです
もし人間の体にも
例えば空間がなくて
空きがなくて
それから体力がないと 骨が弱くて
そうするとおなかの中で大きな赤ちゃんをつけておくことはできないのです
ぶら下がっていることは 体が壊れちゃいます
骨が折れます
その場合は人間も卵を産むでしょう おそらく
そうであったならば
もし将来人間の体がそうやって変わってしまって
骨がもろくなったと
体の中の空洞もどんどん細くなったと
体がすごく軽い方が生きやすくて
重くなったら死ぬ という状態になったら
人間も卵で産む可能性がないわけではないのです
同じDNA ですからね
アメーバからみんな持ってるの
ハエより 少し大きいだけでしょう
人間のDNA というのは
ですから
そんなもの不思議ということでもない
そういうふうに考える人には
そういうふうに見える
絶対的な神様がつくったりするのだという概念を
作っている人には違う角度で見える
ですからこのoctopus（オクトパス）
わかりますか？
タコがすごく変身しますね
「神様がタコが身を守るためによく
作ってあげたのでしょう」と思うかもしれません
普通の自然法則だと思っている人にとっては
それは自然法則ですからね
そうやって身を守るためにいろいろ工夫ができているのだと
どちらにでも証拠あります
例えば　タコの変身というのは
タコが見た世界に限っちゃうでしょう
一度も見たことがないことには変身しません
ですから
タコは違う環境に入れちゃうと
その環境に合わせて変身する
それで自然の主義を持ってる人は
「ですからこれは自然の原因だ」と
それで神様を信仰する人は
「ですから神様はその環境に合わせるように作っているのだ」と
「赤い色は全くない所のタコは赤い色にはなりません
なのに 赤い色の所に連れて行ったところで
すぐに赤い色になることができるでしょう
神様でなければできません そんなこと」
そういう風に我々の知識というのは
自分の得た信仰
信仰というのはちょっと失礼な言葉ですけど
一応 belief（ビリーフ）ですよ
信仰です
宗教的でなくても
例えば 科学信仰しているでしょう
科学も一つの信仰でしょう
いろんなことをみんな信仰しているし
証拠ないけど正しいと思っていることは信仰です
神様を信じることだけが 信仰というわけではないのです
我々もいろんなことを信仰して生きています
ですから
それによっても認識というのは 変わってしまっちゃう
マインドコントロールによっても変わる
それで私の質問は
ですから　知識は当てになりますか？
そんなにも知識に執着して 「私が知ってるのだ」という一言が言えますかと
我々にとってはすべての問題
そこから出てくるのです
私が知ってるのだ
そこから苦しみしか生まれてこないのです
あの人は私の悪口言ってるのだ
私は知ってるのだと 言って自分が苦しみを作る
この人は私をいじめているのだと
それで苦しみを作る
「いいえ いじめていないです」
「あなたは うるさいこと言わないで 失礼なことを」
「被害者は私ですから
いじめられたのは私ですから
あなたに わかるわけないでしょう」と
怒鳴られたりまでする
そこで 「この人に私がいじめられているのだ」と思ったこと自体は 認識でしょう？
大量にデータが入ったところの判断でしょう
当てにならない
ある人が ちょっとした一言もいじめだと思う
ある人が 滅多なことをされない限りは いじめだと思わない
例えば ある若奥さんが姑さんに
「ちょっとこの味噌汁は 薄いのではないかな」と
「ああそう」と言って
「ああそう では ちょっと濃い味にしますよ」 という奥さんもいるかもしれませんし
「それだけのことで なんだ いちいちうるさくて」
「何にでもケチつけてるのではないか」と
「いじめているのではないか」と思う 奥さんもあり得るでしょう
ですから いじめられているのだと言っても
それまたその各人によって違います
学校にしても
いじめられているとか いじめ問題とかにしても
それやっぱり主観です
蹴られただけで
カバンを隠しただけで
いじめられているのだ というふうに受け取る子供もいるし
それは全然いじめだと思わないで
一生懸命 自分のカバンどこにありますか？と
必死になって捜す子もいるし
ですから 必死になって捜す子は 別にそれぐらいのことは いじめだと思わない
時々殴られても いじめだと思わない子供がいるのです
臭いと言われただけで いじめだと思う人もいる
私はいろいろ子供を見たところでも
時々 もうあんた臭いのだから と言われれば
わざと来て体をくっつけたり
いろんなことをする子もいる
ですからその場合は
その子は いじめだと思ってないのです
ああそう だったらもっとやってやるぞと
それでまた他の子は 臭いと言われただけで
いきなり ガクンと落ち込んじゃって
自信がなくなって 暗くなるという場合もあります
ですから
それは どこから生まれる問題かというと
私が知ってるのだということから 生まれるのですよ
この「知ってるのだ」 ということは
本当は 鈍感の結果です
鋭敏の結果ではないのです
それは 最初から説明していたのです
それが 無知の世界です
そこで紹介文章にもあったように
なぜ 私はこうなったのでしょうか？とかね
こんなはずではなかったとか
みんな文句言うでしょう
いろんな不幸に出会っちゃうと
こんなはずではなかったと
なぜ 私にこんなこと起こるのですか？とか
疑問に思ったりする時あるでしょう
気づくともう手遅れで
ある人が 「なぜ私がガンになるのですか」と
私に聞くのです
私は何も返事できませんけど
心の中では 当たり前ではないか という立場ですけど
ですから これは微妙なところから
ほんのちょっとずつ 始まったことで ものすごく
手遅れなぐらいに 大きくなったら 気づいただけ
ですから 子供がいきなり不良になったとかね
いきなり 子供がおかしくなったとか
母が混乱しても 何も意味ないのです
ほんの少しずつ
母親も 周りも その原因を作っていたのです
ただ気がつかないだけ
あまりにも小さいことですから
ほんのわずかなことで 子供を馬鹿にするとかね
それが わからないままですね
どうということないのだと
無関心でいますけど
しかし やがて それ積み重なって 爆発してしまうのです
その時は なぜここまで いい子でいたのに
突然悪くなったのでしょうか と驚いちゃって
いろいろあっちこち走り回って 相談に乗ってもらったとしても
実は手遅れです
ですから 我々が作る問題も
ある日突然会社が倒産したとかね
それはありえないのです
会社の社員たちが 毎秒 毎分 毎時
毎日 やっている行為の結果です
最後に倒産になる
例えば ほんの少しの 判断ミスをしたりする
「まあ それぐらい全然大丈夫だ」と それを無視する
ほんの少しの商売で
1 万、 2万ぐらい損したりする
「まあ それぐらいは当然なことで 関係ないよ」 とか それを無視する
それから 2、3年で 会社が丸ごと倒産したところで びっくりする
そういうことで
みんなが この「無知」で 大変な不幸を招くのです
ある日突然 何か起こるということは ないのです
きちんと順番で
例えば雨というのは
ある日突然降るわけではないのです
突然 空から いきなりドーンと水が落ちた ということはないのです
ゆっくりゆっくりと 空気が変わって
空気の流れが変わって
雲が集まって
それから 微妙に空気の湿気が高くなって
ゆっくりと順番で
それから 大粒の雨が降るようになるのです
ですから 大粒の雨が降った瞬間だけで 我々は気づく
ただ それだけのことです。
しかし 答えというか どうすればいいか ということはね
どうすればいいのですかね その場合は
どんな人間も そういう問題で悩んでます
ですから 我々は 本来は「無知」
針の先で 醤油の味はわからないのだ という状態です
髪の毛 1本だけ体に触れても
そんなことはわかりません という状態でいつでもいるのです
かなり触れないと
そういうことで
我々は データを大量の束にして 知ってるのです
そこら辺は 瞑想でなければ わからないのです
どれぐらいデータが入ったら 認識するかとかね
その個人のレベルを 個々人で発見するしか 方法ないのです
自分のことですからね
そこでこの
1秒の 100分１の時間で 絵や人の顔が ちゃんと入ってます
入ってるのだけど 知らない
それで また入るのですが それでも知らない
それから 0.5秒間ぐらい たくさん映像が入るのです
光の速度を知っているでしょう
ですから 考えてみてください
光の速度で 映像が一つ目に入るのです
丸ごと1枚 映るのです 光の速度で
そこで 光の速度で丸ごと1枚の映像が 映るのだけど
見えてない
大体0.3～0.4秒ぐらい 映ると かすかに見えるのです
ということは
我々は映像をたくさん
無数に 何枚も重ねて束にして
「あ この人の顔です」と 判断してしまうのです
お釈迦様が チャレンジしてというのは
できれば 1枚進めてください
1枚進めてください
音は 音子単位で見てください
映像は 光子単位で見てみてください
そうすると
今まで作った 「私が知っている」という
あの 妄想の世界
あの サンニャー(saññā)の 世界
あの 幻覚の世界が
すぐに 壊れてしまいます
すべてが 根拠のなかったものになります
すべて 主観でしたから
と同時に すべての苦しみも 問題も消えるのです
ですから 仏教の悟りというのは 「智慧」の完成です
「無知」の反対です
解決方法は それしかないのです
他の何をやっても
祈りをしたり 巡礼したりして 治りますか？ その問題は
この認識の問題は 何をしても治りません
お経をあげて 題目をあげて 治ると思いますか?
治らないのです
題目をあげる方々でも
「人生は不幸だ」とかね
「より精神的な 清らかな 人間に
ならなければいけないのだ」 とか思って やっているでしょう
私から見れば 馬鹿もいいところですけど
その判断さえも 間違っているし
これやれば 心清らかになるのだ と思ったこと自体間違っているし
もともとの認識を きちんとしっかりしないと
いけないということですからね
そういうことで 我々が見ているのは 自分の主観で
例えば 1億枚の映像を重ねれば 見えたという人もいて
5000枚の映像を積み重ねれば 見えたという人もいるのです
どちらにも見えてないのです
ただ感受性の差があるだけで
ですから
私達が知っている世界というのは
強引に合成した世界です
例えば 光というのは 一番速いでしょう
目を開ければ それぐらいの速さで
映像がずっと入ってるのです
でも 閉じていて
パッと開けて パッと閉めただけで 見えません
ということは
大量に枚数が入らないと
その入った枚数を 頭の中で 自分で合成するのです
合成して 「あっ見えた」と言うのです
だから　3人で見て
「あっ あれは面白い」
もう一人は「いえ あれは面白くない」 とかね
いろいろ言うのです
例えばヘビを見て
「ああ気持ち悪い」という人もいるし
「ヘビは可愛いではないか」と言って ペットに飼う人もいるでしょう
なぜしょうかね それは
ヘビを見たら 「気持ち悪い」と 思う人が そういう風に合成する
大量の枚数の映像を
頭に入れて ごちゃ混ぜにして 合成して
「ああ気持ち悪い」と決める
もう一人の人は 同じく大量の映像を頭に入れて 合成して
「可愛いではないか」と決める
だから 「ヘビは気持ち悪い」 「ヘビは可愛い」
どちらでも同じことで あてにならない
妄想概念以外の 何もないのです
無知の世界というのは そんな世界で
ですから お釈迦様が 解決方法として
ありのままに 瞬間 瞬間
物事を観察してください
判断しないで 観察してみてくださいと
見えるものは 見える 見えると
音だったら 音 音だけで
そこでうまくいく ということではなくて
どんどんそれやっていると
感受性が どんどん鋭くなるのです
例えば 1億枚でなければ見えなかった人に
五千枚で見えるようになるのです
どんどん 千枚で見えるようにも なるのです
そういうことで
感受性が高く 敏感になればなるほど
世界観が 自動的に変わっていくのです
今まで自分が作った 主観の世界というのは 当てにならないということがわかって
それからは もう脱出する
それについて 悩むことはやめる
「消す」 ということでもなくて 「これは ただの主観です」と
さらに見ていると
物事というのは ずっと変わってるのだという
自分も 見る人も 見られるものも 変わっていくのだよ ということで
そんなものだということで
心が解脱ということを 体験するのですね
ですから そういう過程で
「無明」「無知」を なくしたければ
解脱するということしか 方法はないのです
厳密な話は そこら辺で 終了します
これから 少し休憩して 一般的な話をいたします
ありがとうございます
では　講演始まります
で　あの
この前の説明から考えると
我々が知っている世界というのは
だいたい 当てにならないということまで 話を進めました
ですから
我々はこれを どのように 人生にあてはめるかというと
自分が知ってる世界に あまり しがみつかない方がいいのです
勉強したものであろうとも
聞いたことであろうとも
自分の主観ですからね
その時は　気をつける
それは消せませんよ
勉強したものや 知ったことなどを
「消す」という意味ではないのです
例えば しゃべる場合
「私だったら こういう風に思いますよ」と
「私だったら こういう風にしますよ」と
そういう風に 他人に言う習慣をつけて
自分の判断は 必ずしも 正しいわけではないということを 自分で認めないと
例えば 誰かが 「どうすればいいのでしょうか」と 言う場合は
「いえ こうしなさいよ」 と言うのは 無知な人の生き方で
そうではなくて
その人が一応 「どうすればいいか」 と聞いたのですから
「そうですね 私だったら おそらく こういうふうにするでしょう」 と言って
はっきりと自分の主観を言う
自分の主観しかないのですから
しかし 「故に それが正しい」 というわけではないのです
「私だったら 一応 こういう風にするでしょう」 というふうに 言ってあげる
そうすると 相手の人の主観が
「なるほど これが正しい」 と思ったら 勝手にやるでしょう
あるいは 「いえ違います」 と思ったならば
「それは 違います」 と言うでしょう
私たちの問題は
相手に「勉強しなさい」と言うと
「嫌ですよ」と言われると 腹が立つのですよ
「なぜ 嫌と言うのでしょうか」と
そこがトラブルの元なのです
ですから 「私だったら 今の時間で真面目に勉強しますよ」 と言ったところで
向こうが 「嫌ですよ」と 言うかもしれません
しかし それは その人の主観から見れば
勉強するのは 嫌ということですからね
「ああ そうですか」と
そういう風に
いわゆる 執着しない 知識の世界を ゆっくりと育てる必要があります
それだけで ものすごく 頭が良くなるのです
例えば 「これは塩辛い」 というのではなくて
「私にとっては 少し塩辛く感じますよ」と
そうすると トラブルが起こりません
例えば 人がせっかく一生懸命
褒めてもらいたくて 料理を作ったとする
もともと 褒めてもらいたくて 料理を作った人は
その時点で もう愚か者であることは 確かですけどね
しかし その人が 「これはまずい」と言われちゃうと 大変な出来事になるのです
あるいは逆に まずいものを作っちゃって
それを食べて 強引に笑って 「おいしいですよ」と言うのは
自分にとっては 大変 損をするし
「まずいものはまずい」と 言った方が 自分にとっては得でしょう
だから どうすればいいかと言うと
その場合は
「私だったら もう少し柔らかい方が いいでしょう」とかね
「私の感覚では もう少し味があった方が いいと思いますよ」とかね
それは あくまでも 「私の感覚では」 と言うと
本人から見れば 自分にとっては
本人が 「いえ これは 最高においしい」と言って
「あ そうですね」 それで終わっちゃう
問題解決しますよ
相手方の立場から見れば
これは最高に美味しいのですけど
こちらの主観から見れば
もう少し味を付けた方がいいって
ただ味を付けた方がいいという
個人的な意見だけですよ と言えば 全然トラブルは起こりません
なぜ そういうふうに しゃべれるかというと
自分の知識は 絶対的に正しいという立場を 取ってないのですから
今まで説明した話から
それ正しくなるはずがない
それを理解しておけば
すごく気楽に トラブルを起こさずに 生きていられます 人間には
ですから そういうふうに 使用してください
子供が父に何か言う場合も
「これやれ これやれ」ではなくて
「私が こういうふうなことを やってほしいな」とかね
自分の意見を言うと
父親が「いえ これはこういうわけで
私は あまり やってあげたくないのですよ」 とかね
と言ったところで 喧嘩にはなりません
そういうことだったら いくらか 話し合いということも 成り立つ
今 我々はいっぱい ディスカッションやら 会議やら やってますけど
みんな自分の主観
自分の我見を バンバン出すだけであって
誰も聞いてない
20人集めれば 20人とも
「これだ これだ」と言うだけで
一人一人が 自分が言っていることは そのとおりで正しいのだ
そんなことでは 会議にも ディスカッションにも 話し合いにも 何にもなりません
私もかなりそういうことで 痛めつけられているのですから
こちらは人の意見は聞きますけど
聞いたからといって
その意見は 完璧に正しい ということではないでしょう
そこで いろいろな 他の意見と照らし合わせて
いくらか有効な プラクティカル（実用的）な意見を 一応 作ったところで
向こう側が機嫌が悪い
私の意見が無視されたのだと
では私は参加しませんと
という態度を取っちゃうのですね
それは あまりにも 我執で あまりにも 我見に 囚われて
あまりにも無知ですね
そうすると人間付き合いというのは まるっきり成り立たない
大変なことですよ
二人が話し合うということは
もともと成り立たないことですから
いわゆる 共同的な経験は ないのですから
お腹が空いたと言っても 同じ経験ではないでしょう
ですから もともと成り立たないことを やってますよ
人と仲良くするということは
その上 我執でいると
もうどうにもならないのです
ですから そういう人々は 社会から追い出される
「では 私は辞めます」と
その人は 平気で言う
辞めて楽しいかというと
喧嘩して辞めただけであって
何でもかんでも 辞めることも 知恵ではないし
物事をうまく運ぶことが知恵です
嫌だから辞めたというのも
バカだから辞めた ということでしょうし
ですから 世の中で何でもかんでも
「じゃあ 辞める 辞める」
そんな簡単ではないのですけど
知恵のある人は 何でもかんでも 「辞める 辞める」ではなくて
有効に みんなのために どうやって物事を運ぶかと
それを考えるのです
ですから
みんなの意見を聞いて
それを合わせてみて
それなりに いろいろ調整をして
「どんな意見が 通用するか 否か」 ということは 決めなければいけないのです
ですから
我々はよく平和で無事で
それから仲良く
社会の人間として 幸福で生きていきたければ
この無知ということには 十分に気をつけることです
気をつけて 我見に 我執に とらわれない
そうすると 喧嘩ということは 成り立たないのです
喧嘩が成り立たないということは
けして 意見違いはあり得ない ということではありませんよ
夫婦は 別々な意見が あるかもしれませんよ
別々の意見を持っても 喧嘩にはなりません
相手が 私の意見では
私の気持ちとしては こういうことだよと
向こう側が 全く違うことを 言うかもしれません
いきなり暴言吐いて
「なんで あんた そんなことを 言うのでしょうか」と
いきなりコブラみたいに かかっていくでしょう
それが 「愚か者」なのです
自分の意見に 全く正反対のことを 言われても
「ああ そうですか」
それだけのことです
それはその人の意見でしょうし
こちらはこちらの意見でしょうし
どちらにしても主観ですから
そんなに 当てになるものではないし
相手が「自分の意見が正しい」
「そんなに いちいち神経質にならなくても
落ち着きなさいよ」と
「人というのは いろいろな意見を持っているのだから」とか
「もっと大人になりなさいよ」と
青い色が好きな人もいて
嫌いな人もいて
いろいろいるのですから
という風に 言ってあげればいいでしょう
ですからこの
特に日本にあること 「強引にまとめる」という
「和合」とか あんなうるさい嘘ばかり言って
「和合」も「調和」もないのです この社会でも
私の悪口で言えば
日本で何がないかというと  「和合」と「調和」なのです
しかし日本の方々は
日本文化として 日本が世界に売るものだったら
「和合」と「調和」だよ と言ってるでしょう
私は 別に外国人としてではなくて
一人の出家僧としゃべる場合は
日本人に何がないかというと
「和合」と「調和」です
会社にしても
学校にしても
家にしても
強引に決まりを決めて 強引に無理やり それに合わせているのです
これは 和合ではなくて もう 残酷
何て言いますかね
虐待というかね
あまりにも 残酷なのです
tortureという言葉が 英語でありますね
torture 何だっけ?
拷問に使う言葉ですけど
ひどく痛めつけて
拷問なのです
ですから みんな結局は 拷問されて 怖くて
合わせているだけではないですか
それが 「和合」と「調和」と言えますか
仏教の立場からですよ
私は 一外国人として見ると
確かに 「和合」と「調和」がありますよ と言いますけど
仏教徒としては言いません
ブッダの立場からは言いません
ですから本当に 「和合」と「調和」があると
すごく気楽で穏やかで
ストレスも何もなくて
なんとも美しいのですよ
一人が二人になると
そちらに和合が成り立つでしょう
ものすごく穏やかになるのです
3人になると もっと立派な和合が できるのだから
ずいぶんと 気楽になるはずです
実際はどうですかね
実際はどうですか
人の数が増えれば増えるほど
ものすごく ぎゅうぎゅうと きつくなるでしょう
ですから仏教というのは
全ての価値観を捨てる世界 ですから
残念なことに 日本の価値観は 捨てなければいけないのです
西洋と比べて 日本の価値観は 素晴らしいと
それは 比較するだけのことで
どんな価値観も 捨てなければいけないのです
それでなければ 幸せというのは 出てこないのです
ですから 「和合」と「調和」というのは 素晴らしいこと
これを お釈迦様は 認めています
何でも 「和合」と「調和」で やらなければ
苦しいのだと
仲良く 仲良くと
しかし それが世の中でないのです
お釈迦様がいう 「仲良く」ということは
自分の主観に
自分の我見に しがみついていることではないのです
それが あまりもアホくさいと
自分の主観
我見というのはね
みんなそれぞれに 我見ばっかり持っていて
お互いに罵り合ったり
ぶつかっているのだよと
だから大人は みんなの意見は
その場合は そういう風にも言えますよ と
こういう風にも 言えますよと
では 我々みんな集めて
どういう風にすればよろしいかな とかね
みんなで考えましょうと
それが和合です
みんなで考えれば 反対意見は ないはずです
これで この世界で みんなで考えましょうと 考えて結論を 出したところで
「俺が反対 だから帰る」と
「ああ なるほど」と 私は思いますね
ですから
仏教では民主主義ですけど
多数決ではないのです
お釈迦様は 多数決は認めません
お釈迦様にとっては
多数決というのは 民主主義ではなくて 独裁主義
だって多数の意見でしょう
少数はどうしますか？
独裁です
100人を集めたところ 99人が1つの意見で
１人が違う意見
仏教だったら通りません
「99人の意見だから それにしましょう」 と言ったところで
1人の意見は？
それは 独裁です 99人の
我々がいうのは 100人集めたところで 99人が違う意見を持っている
１人がまた 違う意見を持っている
それで １人が自分の意見を通してしまう
そうすると 我々は「独裁」と言うのですね
「独断判断で あなたは よく やっているのだよ」とかね
批判するでしょう
仏教は両方
我々 俗世間では 「90人の意見だから
我々はしっかりと民主主義でやっていますよ」と
仏教では 違います
それも独裁的で
90人の意見を抑えて １人の意見を通してしまうと
それも独裁的
ですから話し合うということは
お互いに話し合って
話し合って
それぞれの意見の長も短もね
考えてみて
そういうことですから
こういう風にしましょう と決めることです
そうすると
それは みんなの意見でなければいけません
誰にも反対する権利はないのです
みんなで話し合って作った意見ですから
ですから
仏教の民主主義というのは 「全員一致」 ということになっているのです
わかりますかね
お釈迦様が 考えている 「和合」と「調和」というのは
どれほど厳密かと
ですから それが通用しているのは 出家の世界だけです
お釈迦様は どうせ話を聞いてくれない ということを知っていたのですから
出家組織を作ったのです
別に 「出家しなければ悟れない」とか
そんなことは非科学的ですからね
言ってないのですけど
どうも言うことを聞いてくれないし
とにかくモデルでもね
サンプルでもね
作っておきましょうと
ということで
お釈迦様は 自分の知恵から見た平和な世界
問題を作らない世界をね
特別に人々を取って
ある組織を作ってみたのです
ですから サンガの世界では 個人の意見は通りません
主観は通りません
個人で財産さえ 持ってはいけないのです
常に和合でやらなければいけない
異論があったら すぐに話し合いなさいと
みんなで話し合って うまくいかないのだったら
大騒ぎになるのだったら
人数が多くて
それだったら
審査会を作りなさい
賢者たちの何人かの
例えば 100人のお坊さんがいて
一人が すごく変な意見を出したとします
すると 100人のお坊さんたちも いろいろな意見を言っていると
どうしても落ち着いてこないのですね
その場合 サンガがどうしますか というと
この 100人のお坊さんたちの中から 一番智慧のある
一番優秀な 1～2人を選んで 審査会を設定します
そこで 審査会で 調べるのです
その一つの問題を
調べて 審査会で判決を出すのです
正しい意見は こういう意見だといって
この審査会と この問題を起こした人と
みんなが またサンガの100人の集まりに入って
では 発表いたしますと
結論を 発表します
そうすると みんな全員一致で じゃあ賛成します
反対はできません
反対できませんと言うと
なんか すごく厳しいのではないかと
そういう意味の反対ではないのです
それが「和合」であって 「調和」です
仏教に基づいて
戒律に基づいて
審査会の長老たちが きちんと判断したのですから
個人の 私の 好みではダメです
ということになるのです
ですから
理想的な民主主義というのは
サンガの世界でのみ あるのであって
普通の世界ではありえないし
ないのです
不可能というわけではない
もう少し頭が良ければ
人間に和合というのは作れますよ
そういうことですから
幸せで豊かで生きていきたければ
すごく簡単なポイントというのは
あまり私意見に囚われないこと
捨てなさいということではありません
捨てられるものではないのですから
それが私の意見だと
私見だと
肉が嫌いという人がいるならば
「捨てなさいよあなたの考え方は」と
「肉は美味しいと思いなさい」って 言っても無理でしょう
ニンジン嫌いだと 思ってる人がいるのだったら
「あなたそんな主観でね
何やってるのですか
みんなが食べてる食べ物だから 好きになりなさい」と言ったって
こんな無理な話で
ですから
自分の私見を捨てなさい ということではなくて
私見にとらわれてはいけない というぐらいのことです
ですから
「私にとってはニンジンは 少し口に合わないのですよ」と言えば
みんな「そうでしょうかね
我々にとっては美味しいけど
ではそこらへん何とかしましょう」と
「あなたのために ニンジン抜きで料理しましょう」と
ふうになりますし
あるいは 「あなたのために ニンジン抜き料理はできませんが
ニンジンを取って食べられるように 作りますよ」
というぐらいの調和が成り立つでしょう
独裁主義だったら
「では ニンジンを潰して ペースト状態に作って 料理に入れましょう」と
そうすると
ニンジン嫌いな人には 嫌いなものを取ることさえ できなくなってしまうでしょう
それが独裁的なやり方
調和というのは
ニンジン嫌いな人に ニンジン好きになりなさい ということではないのです
今の社会ではそうさせてるのです
学校に行っても
会社に行っても
激しい 規則に しきたりに 決まりに 縛られてるのです
地方によって わけのわからない 決まり しきたり というのが いっぱいあって
他の地方から お嫁に行った人だったら
もう地獄の苦しみですね
何もわからないのですから
そこは調和とは言えません
そんなものは拷問すぎです
ですから　東京の女の子が 随分遠い東北とか どこでもいいのですけど
お嫁に行ったならば
そこは 全く考え方と 世界が 違いますから
ゆっくりお互いの意見を交わし合って
友好的な生き方を 作ればいいでしょう
それが 無知で悩まない方法ですね
無知な人は 仏教では「愚か者」 と呼ぶのですね
「愚か者」ということは
私は 何回も文章に書きましたが
これは差別用語ではありません
これは みんなに まとめて言ってることです
愚か者でないというのは 「主観」を捨てた人だけです
それはもう悟らなければ
ですから今説明した
今 現代風に 心理学的に 少し論理的に 説明したのだから
「無知」の過程を
ですから
そこを仰ってるだけなのです
ですから愚か者と言って
お釈迦様が こういうふうに 教えるのです
この世の中で 危険が生まれるならば
すべては愚か者から生まれる
智慧のある人からは生まれません
災難が生まれるならば
愚か者から 無知の人から 災難が生まれる
賢者からは災難が生まれません
大損 ひどく損すること
一応 3つの言葉ありますけど
ほとんど危険
災難ぐらいでもわかりますね
人がひどく損して
すごく悲しいことになるのだったら
これは愚か者の結果ですよ
決して賢者からは そういうものは生まれてこないのだと
そこで お釈迦様は 「全て」とか
総括的な言葉というのは 気をつけて使う
例えば 「みんなそうですよ」というのは ものすごくいい加減な言い方でしょう
「これだったらみんな嫌いますよ」と みんな簡単に言うでしょう
お釈迦様はそんなこと 言わないのです
「これはみんな嫌いますよ」 と言っても
みんなに聞かなければ わからないことでしょう
ですから 「みんな」 「すべて」 「一切」
それは 一番 気をつけなければいけない 言葉ですね
しかしこの場合
お釈迦様は 「すべて」という言葉を きちんと使っているのです
「一切」という言葉を 使っているのです
Yāni kānici, bhikkhave, bhayāni uppajjanti sabbāni tāni bālato uppajjanti.
sabba ；一切
恐怖感が生まれるならば
すべてが愚か者から生まれる
愚か者のせいで生まれるのだ
無知のせいで生まれるのだよ
ですから恐怖感嫌だと
災難嫌だと 悲しみ嫌だと
損するのは嫌だと思うのだったら
我々は主観にしがみつくことをやめる
それで結論を出します
お釈迦様が
Iti kho, bhikkhave, sappaṭibhayo bālo,
故に比丘らよ 愚か者というのは ものすごく危険である
appaṭibhayo paṇḍito.
賢者は 平安なところですよ
安全なところ 避難所ですよ
saupasaggo bālo
愚か者というのは いつでも悩み事を 作るものです
anupasaggo paṇḍito
賢者は悩むことを消すのだと
saupasaggo bālo
愚か者が 災難ですよ
賢者が 平安ですよ
ですから
愚か者と 賢者を 区別しなさいよと
ですから 私も愚か者に なってはいけないし
それから 人と付き合う時も 気をつけないといけないのですよ
愚か者がね
主観主義者が言うことに 乗せられると 必ず危険があるのです 必ず
ですから 我々は 簡単に人の意見に乗せられる という状態
振り回される状態というのは
これは 自分に 本当に 判断能力がない ということになってしまうのです
人の意見は客観的に聞く
自分の意見も客観的にする
そうすると振り回される 乗せられる ということはないのですね
ですから 我々が社会で生きていても
人の意見を聞きながら 注意をする必要があります
この人は 主観でしゃべっているか
客観的に 情報を取って 発表しているか とか
ただ 自分の意見
「私の意見こそ正しいのだから これ やれ」という
独裁的な感じで 言っているかとか
チェックできるでしょう
チェックすれば
この人は愚か者であると
ですから危険の種ですよと
火種ですよと
それで気をつけましょうと
火種でも何か道具を使うと
手は火傷しませんからね
それで 愚か者を判断する方法というのは いろいろありまして
身体で何かやろうとしたら
これまた 悪いことばっかりやる
Kāya-duccarita  悪いこと
しゃべると悪いことばかり言う
考えると 変な いけないことを考える
それでわかるでしょう
人が何かやっていることを見ると
それは行儀のよい 立派な行為か
品のない いい加減な行為か
すぐ見えるでしょう
それだけでわかります
しゃべると 言葉にすごく気をつけて 客観的にしゃべりますか？
あるいは感情的になって
私はこういうことだ という風にしゃべるかとかね
あまりにも 主観的で激しくしゃべるのだったら
もう 智慧がないということですね
なので 人の考え方は もう聞いたらわかるでしょう
私はこういう意見だ
こういう意見だと言うでしょう
それで意見を聞いてみれば
なんか変な意見だと
おかしい意見だと
ものすごく偏見的だとわかったら
この人は要注意にするのです
それで この人が無知な人であると
この人は愚か者であると 誰に理解できますか？
というと
みんなに理解できません
賢者にのみ理解できる
今 おっしゃったのは 賢者になる方法です
完璧になる方法ではなくて
賢者もどきみたいかもしれませんし
賢者かぶりかもしれません
それでもうまくいくのです
自分の主観は 主観であることは認識して
「私の意見は こういうふうな意見ですけど」 という態度で生きてみる
「私から見れば こういうふうなことになりますけど」 とかね
そうやって 主観にとらわれないように 訓練すると
いくら か賢者かぶりかもしれませんけど
修行してないのですから
しかしそれでもしなければ
それは 決して 悪いことではないのです
そうすると相手のことがわかります
自分が主観主義だったら
決して相手のことはわからない
例えば喧嘩するときは
みんな 感情的に 言いたい放題のことばっかり言って 喧嘩するでしょう
誰も人の話を聞いてないでしょう
終わってから聞いてみてください
「あなたはこういうことを言った」と
「はい 言いました」と
「相手は どのように反応したのでしょうか」と
全然聞いてないのです
ですから 愚か者に 愚か者の判断はできません
ですから賢者が人の話を見て
人の行為を見て
人の思考を見て
この人は無知な人であると決める
決めて 身の安全を図る
もう一つあります
「愚か者を判断できる方法」 というのは
愚か者というのは 間違いを認めないのです
いろいろと失敗するでしょう
変なことするので 間違いを起こすでしょう
愚か者が間違いを認めません
全然認めません
そこで 賢者が 自分が間違えたら
「間違えました」と
「これは間違えました」と
「これは失敗です」と すぐ認める 堂々と
それだけでも すごく立派な人なのです
だけど みんな ごまかしをする
言い逃れをする
隠そうとする 間違いを
だから 自分の失敗
自分の間違い
ごまかすならば
隠そうとするならば
自分自身が正真正銘の愚か者です
そこで相手のことを見ても
相手が間違っているのに 全然認めないこと
よくごまかすこと とかわかるでしょう
そうすると 相手も無知な人だと
そこで 間違っても愚か者が 直さないのですよ
「それでいいのだ」と
「間違って何が悪いのですか？」
と言いながら また間違っちゃうのです
いくら仏教が 慈しみの世界と言っても
「仏様は三回まで」 と言うのだから 三回までです
それ以上はもう付き合わない
もう出て行く
時間の無駄だと
ですから
間違えたら 教えてあげたりする
それでも 直さない場合とか
態度を変えて
「だから何でしょうか」とか
「それぐらいは いいのではないか」と言うと
賢者が
「まあ それぐらいは 別に どうってことはないのですけど
間違いを認めて 直してください」と言っても
また 間違いをするのだったら
また 言ってあげる
また 間違いをしたら また 言ってあげる
それで終わり
付き合いも終わり
そうでなければ この世の中で 生きていられません
ですから
愚か者のやり方というのは
間違いは まず認めない
それから直さない
それから もう一つあります
他人の間違いは 決して許さない
これ　愚か者の生き方です
例えば何か間違いを起こしたら
ごめんなさいとかね
おわびしますとかね
他人が言うと
それで なかったことにするのですよ 賢者は
「ああそう じゃあ まあいい
もう そんなこと関係ない」と
「では なかったことにしましょう」と
本気でなかったことにします
賢者は 相手の間違いは
愚か者の場合は 相手が間違って
すみません
もう間違えました
ごめんなさいと言って
いくら言っても怒鳴ったり
いろんなことをしたりするのです
一生忘れません
それだけは 頭が悪いわりには
人の過ちだけは ずっと覚えておく
それが 愚か者の生き方なのですね
それで 無知な人かどうかの 判断をしてください
行為で それから 失敗って誰でもするのだから
簡単に 判断できます
失敗したら
「これは失敗だ」と
なんのことなく認める人が かなり立派な人なのです
人の失敗は「まあいいではないか」と 許してあげるのだったら
立派なことなのです
それから
話し合う時も 無知な人を発見できます
例えば 質問する時は よく考えて質問しない
とにかく質問する
いわゆる質問というのは
何か疑問が起きて
例えば私の場合
私が言ったことについて 何か疑問が起きて
自分の意見があって
そこで ぶつかったりすると
そこは質問にしますよという風に 明確に質問を作らなければいけないのですね
そうではなくて
とにかく 何か言ったら 何か言う
これ何かと また何か言うという
これも気をつけた方がいいのです
でなければ
私は もう体がもたなくなっちゃってるのです 最近
本当に 考えないで 質問する人々いるのですね
私は明確に見せてあげるのです
「あなたは何も考えてないのだ」と
そうした ところで
また逆に 「そうではないか」
「こうではないか」
「ああではないか」と
また来るのです
そこで私は
2回目でストップするわけです
例は出せますけど
これはあまり良くないのですからね
それから この愚か者に質問しても 明確に答えないのですね
なんとかごまかす
「なんとか そうでも ああでも」 と何か言って 何か言い返す
そこで 頭のいい人は 質問されれば
その質問を 綺麗に分析して 綺麗に答えるのです
きちんと
ただ言い返すだけでは 答えではないのです
ですから質問に答える時でも
知恵のある人か ない人か ということはわかるのです
それからもう一つ
例えば宗教の世界でもね
私が言うことには 当然異論というのはありますからね
世の中は違う意見を持ってるのですから
それで違う意見を持ってる人が話し合いになる
例えば 私にできるわけではないのだけど
明確に分析して 証拠を出して
こういうことですよと きちんと説得しても
「でも 認めません」 と言うと
正真正銘の愚か者です
異論があって質問出したところで
それに 厳密に答えたならば
答えが正しければ認めるべきです
「いや 私は 20年こういうことを やってきたのですから やめません」と
だったらどうぞ
こちらに 関係ある人ではありません ということになるのです
ですから 知恵のある人の判断というのは その2つ
質問すると ぐちゃぐちゃで
質問自体は明確ではない
答える時でも 何か言い返すだけであって
全部把握して答えようとしない
それで 答えられた場合でも
きちんと 納得させてくれたのに 認めないという
3つのポイント
覚えておいてください
例えば あの人には いくら説明しても認めませんと やってくれませんと言うと
その人は 頑固ということでしょう
人の話を聞かないということでしょう
自分の意見に しがみついているということでしょう
もう愚か者です
例えば 私だったら 絶対こんなことは認めません と言っている人でも
話し合った結果
やっぱり考え方を直します と言ったならば
頭のいい人です
そういうふうなことで
知恵のない人が 人のことを判断できます
それからもう一つ
この愚か者というのは
愚か者の生き方
無知な人の生き方というのは
自分の穴を自分で掘る生き方です
自分の墓穴を自分で掘る
いわゆる自分を掘ってるのです
自我を 自己を
ですから人の生き方を見て
この人は自己破壊ではないかと
そんなことしたら
例えば子供があまり勉強しないと
どうせ自己破壊の道でしょう
ですから 勉強しないのだったら 頭が悪いということに どうせなるしね
頭が悪くても 一生懸命真面目に 苦労して 勉強していると
この子は自分の将来を 考えているのですね
ですから 「嫌だから勉強しませんよ」 とか
「難しいからしませんよ」 と言うと 自己破壊ですよ
それはもう 愚か者の判断の基準 なのです
大人にしても同じことで
悪いこととか何かやって
こんなことやったら自己破壊ですよと
例えば 金を無駄遣いするわ
十分に 収入を得るように頑張らないと 自己破壊でしょう
無知な人ですね
例えば いろいろな依存症で
アルコールや タバコや 競馬やらね
いろんなものに依存して
そこで快楽を感じると
明確に自己破壊の道でしょう
そうやって 自己破壊の道に行く人々は
もうまとめて 無知な人ということになるのです
知恵のある人が いつでも自分のことを気をつけて
自己破壊へは 行ってはいけないということで 気をつけるのです
子供から大人まで
無知な人の判断は それぐらいでできます
そういうふうに判断して
我々は 気をつけなければ いけないのですね
それで 私たち個人でも
本当に 鈍感でないようにと 気をつけなくては いけないのですね
ですから
修行しなくても瞑想すると
厳密に 心理のレベルで解決しますけど
みんなに修行できるわけでもないし
時間もないのですから
日常生活の中で 我々は よく目を開けておく
耳をよく開いておく
いわゆるものをよく見る
人の話もよく聞く
理解する
そういう生き方を しなければいけない
あまり主観に 囚われないようにする
大体 私はこういうものだ
こういうものだとか 決めない方が いいのですよ
ということはね
私は日本人ですから これしか食べませんよとかね
別に何の意味もないのですけどね
そんなこと言っても
私はこういう地方でしか 住めませんよとかね
私はこんな感じの人としか 付き合いませんよとかね
そうやって 「硬い私」を作らない方がいいのです
すごく 自我を柔軟性になるようにする
そういうことで目を開けておく
耳を開いておく
目も耳も
私たちが子供の頃に 言われた言葉がありまして
「あなたは 知ってますか？」
「人には 目はいくつありますか?」と 「2つですよ」
「耳はいくつありますか？」 「2つですよ」
「では 口は？」 「口は一つですよ」
「それはなぜでしょうか？」と聞いたら
目は 2つあるのだから 物を よく 2倍見なさいと
耳が 2つあるのだから 物事をよく聞きなさいよ
口一つありますから しゃべる時はすごく気をつけて 少なくしゃべります
ですから 正しく 情報を受けとる ということを教えていて
しゃべる時は 十分に気をつけて
自分の主観を ボンボン出すのではなくて
気をつけていると 結構うまくいくと思います
だいたい 大きなポイントというのは それぐらいで 全部終わりますが
細かいことは またいろいろと言えます
それで もう一つポイントがあります
それで終了します
貪瞋痴を発見する方法
例えば綺麗な何かを見たら
すごく可愛い犬を見たら ああ可愛いと すぐにわかりますね
綺麗な花を見れば すごく綺麗な花ですよと
すぐに わかります
それが 欲ですね
すぐわかります
それで嫌なことを聞いたら
嫌な音ですよとかね
嫌なものが口に入れれば
これは嫌いですよと
すぐわかります
ですから人というのは
怒りと欲というのは 簡単にわかります
しかし 怒りと欲が 無知という土台で 現れるものなのです
無知という土台が 一貫してみんなにあります
修行しない限りは
それで 怒りと欲が出てくるのですね
それで こういうふうなことに 無知がよく働くのですね
例えば 何か見れば面白いと思って それに惹かれる
それが欲
面白くない
嫌いだと思っちゃうと
それから離れる
それに攻撃する
それが怒り
他のものに対しては
我々は あまり面白くないと無視する
ですから 1時間生きてみると
面白いとか 嫌ということは ほとんど少ないのです
1時間 ただぼーっと座ってみましょう
いろんな音が聞こえる
いろんなものは見えるし
その 1時間の間で
すごく面白いと 惹かれる感覚というのは 少ないでしょうし
それが嫌だとかね
気持ち悪いというふうに 攻撃したくなる感覚も少ないでしょう
大体 1時間ぼーっと座っていると
なんとなく面白くないというかね
軽々く面白くないとかね
退屈とかね
ということになるのです
その時 我々は無視 という行動をするのです
惹かれるか
反発するか
無視するか
物について
対象に惹かれるか
対象に反発するか
あるいは無視するか
無視する間は 無知が機能しているのです
ということで
我々は1時間で かなりの量に 無知を育てているのです
大変な問題です
それを直す方法というのは
どんなものにも興味を持って 興味に溢れる人間になりることです
そうすると みるみるうちに頭が良くなるのです
今 テレビでも料理研究家やら 片付けのプロやら
いろいろな くだらないことにまで プロがいるでしょう
片付けのプロがいるのだぞ
インテリアのプロがいるのだぞ
それでインテリアの中でも カラーコーディネーションのプロがいるのだとか
料理はあまりできないのだけど
料理を設定することのプロがいるのだとか
商売は下手ですけど
店のディスプレイの 陳列するときのプロがいるとかね
それでいろんなくだらないことにまで プロがいる世界でしょう
なぜそんなになるのでしょうか
その人々はある一つのものに すごく興味を持ってるのです
よくテレビでね
放送時間でも たくさん使っているのは 女性のお化粧のためですからね
それで 痩せて見せる方法とかね
目を より大きく見せる方法とかね
そういう幻覚のプロがいるのですね
目は目ですけど
お化粧でいろいろハイライトしたり
シャドウを入れたり
いろんな工夫をして
大きく見せる
唇は本当に ものすごく太いのですけど
お化粧の仕方によって 細く見せるとかね
それもプロがいて
すごくお金も取る
私が言いたいのは
どんなものにも
これ何？ なぜこういう風にあるのでしょうか？
というね
そうやって どんなものにも興味を持つと
人生一貫して面白いのです
家にゴキブリがいた途端
いきなり怒りだして
ああ 嫌だと キャーキャーと言うのではなくて
どんな形のゴキブリですか とかね
歩き方はどういうことですかとかね
どこに隠れているのでしょうかとかね
それについても興味を持つ
どんなつまらないことでも 興味を持つと
そのことからすごく喜びも出てくるし
頭も良くなるし
ですから この科学者というのは
子供の頃から 何かに凝って興味を持つ人々でしょう
ですから ある一つに興味を持つのではなくて
一般的に人生について
毎日の出来事について
電車に乗れば 電車にいる人々について
立ち方について
ちょっと見てみるとかね 私みたいに
電車に乗ったら いろいろ広告あるでしょう
全部読みますから
今は目が見えなくなって 読めなくなっちゃったのだけどね
大きな文字以外は
しかし読める時は全部読む
別にそれでもって何か知識得る
ではなくて やっぱり何か知識を得られるのです
それでもって 私は みんなどうやって 何を考えているか
どういう風に騙されているでしょうか とかね
全部騙し文句ですからね
こんなものにも 騙される人いるでしょうとかね
ですから そんな広告書いてるのだろうとかね
それで私はかなり勉強になるのです
みんなの思考パターンまで 広告を読んだだけで
それで 全く屁理屈で 論理的には 何も関係ないのだけど
いろいろ つなげているとかね
これとこれ 何にも関係ないのに 繋げて広告出しているということは
人間が なんとかして 好き勝手に繋げるでしょう とかね
すごく人気のある人の 顔写真を出して
ろくに役に立たない品物を 側に置いておく
それでみんな 買っちゃうのです
そういう 人間の弱みを握っているところ とかね
愚かさを握ってますけど 弱みというより
ですから そうやって電車に乗ったら
そこら辺にも いろんなことに興味を持つ
毎日ご飯を研ぐかもしれませんけど
毎日違うのだよと
毎日研ぐご飯にしても
毎日興味を持つ
毎日の掃除でもマンネリではなくて
毎日違いますよ
興味を持つ
そうすると
あの無視という機能が消えちゃう
それで智慧が現れてくると思います
それですごく楽しく生きていられます
退屈というのは なくなってしまうのです
いつでも精神的に元気で 青年でいられます
話はそこら辺で終了いたします
どうもありがとうございます
「時間の方は少し過ぎてるのですが
質問のある方は していただいても大丈夫です」
「どうぞ遠慮しないで」
「はい　質問します
愚か者を見た時に
その人が 自分の意見をガンガン言って 直さないという時に
この人はいいや というふうにしてしまうと
同じ会社の中で仕事してる場合に
人間関係が 非常に悪くなってくるのですね
ですから
基本的なスタンスとしては
慈しみの心といいますか そういうものが なければいけないのかな
という気はしてるのですけども
ですから
賢者は もうあの人はいいや というふうに 言えるかもしれないのですが
愚か者が 愚か者に対する時には
もう少し違うやり方を やらないといけないのかな というふうに思ったのですけども
何かいいアドバイスありますか？」
実践してみれば 多分問題にならないと思いますけど
自分が主観を出さないのだったら ぶつからないのですからね
最初から言ったのだから
自分が 私の場合は こういう意見ですと言ってあげれば
相手が自分の主観を いくら頑固でガンガン言ったとしても
ぶつからないのです
人間関係悪くなるのは
「私の意見これですよ  これ聞きなさい」
という立場を取っちゃうとなんです
ですから
問題に全くなりません
人間関係まずくなりません
まずくなるのは
あの人 あんな意見持ってるのだけど
絶対認めませんよ という言葉なのです
だから無視してやるぞと
すると立場がまずいのです
ではなくて
その人はそういう意見で
私だったらこういう意見ですけど
ということで 止まるのだから 問題にはならないのですね
そこでどうしても付き合う場合は
例えば その人の意見が全く違う とわかっても
「本当はね
私たちは こういうふうなことをしますけど
そちらは 本当に 反対であるということは よくわかりますけど
申し訳ないのですよ」 と言っちゃえば それだけです
「反対ということは よく知ってますけど
その理由も知ってますけど
今の場合は ちょっと申し訳ない
ちょっと勘弁してくれ」と
そういうふうに 知恵を使うのです
それから 本当に とんでもない
悪いこと 危険なことばかり やってる時でも
付き合う方法はありますね
ものすごく熱いものは どうやって取るのですか？
「布か何かで」
何かで取るでしょう
ですから素手で取らないことです
ですから注意 気づくという道具を いつでも前に持っていく
慈悲というのは もっと違う次元のことで
生命は 幸せでいてほしいということでね
ですから
人には攻撃しないということでね
賢者もあんた出て行けと言ったとしても 慈悲がないわけではないのです
慈悲で言ってるのです
追い出されたところで
その人は気づく可能性もあるし
あるいは逆に 愚か者に一生付き合って 賢者の時間がなくなっちゃって
育てられる人々は 1万人 2万人も ダメになってしまう
それ自体が
どれほど いけないかということ
ですから賢者が 慈悲をもって 追い出すのです
あなたに付き合うために
私は3時間使っても あなたは理解はしません
しかし この3時間で
他の人々だったら 100人でも心が直りますよ
ですから 100人地獄に落とすのですかね
あるバカ者と付き合うために
付き合っても その人は天界に行かないのですから
自分を直さないのですからね
それはしょうがないのです
ですから賢者の態度というのは
それ自体も 慈しみの行為です
我々は どんな生命でも 幸福でいてほしい ということは基本的なことで
それと これは ぶつからないのです
「どうですか？ もう一方 質問ありましたらどうぞ」
「センシブルということについての 質問ですが
先ほどのお話で
理解が間違っていなければ
生命体が 何かを センシブルな状態になった時は
もう遅いというふうに おっしゃったと思うのですが
人間に限らずですね
全ての生命というのは
どこか 世界の片隅に生きているわけですね
魚は水の中とか
人間はまあこういうところです
ミミズは土の中に住む
その自分が住んでいる片隅の中で
生命体として生きるわけですから
その片隅の中で
生きるということは
おそらく内外からの情報を分析して
自分が生きるために必要な 情報をキャッチして
危険が迫れば逃げる
生きるために必要な栄養分を取るとか
必要最小限の情報をキャッチしてると思うのですね
例えば ミミズで言えばよくわかりますが
例えば音ですね
振動は 音を作る感覚ではないですか
その時に非常に微細な振動だと
アリが近づいてくる音まで 感じる必要はない
しかし ミミズの外敵が 仮にイノシシだとしましてね
イノシシが近づいてくる時に
イノシシの音をキャッチした瞬間に もう逃げられなければ ミミズとして生きられませんから
おそらく イノシシの足音が 危険なところに近づいてくる
そうとう以前のところで イノシシの振動を キャッチするようにできてると思うのですね
ですから
その感じた瞬間に もう遅いということではなくて
センシブルということは
そのミミズなら ミミズの生存に必要な
その十分手前の段階で センシブルになるのではないかな というふうに思うのですが
ですから センシブル
ミミズが自分の生命に 危険のある振動をキャッチする タイミングというのは
アリの足音を感じないとすれば
それは自分の生存にとって必要な
十分必要な安全
自分の安全を確保するために
十分ゆとりを持った段階で センシブルになるようにできているのであって
ですから
不必要な音に対しては 無知であるとは思いますけれども
センシブルになった瞬間に もう遅いということはないのではないか という気はちょっとするのですけども
お釈迦様の教えと 直接関係はないですけど」
おっしゃってることは
それは当たり前のことだと 思いますけど
犬は音に敏感でいるのが 必要でしょうし
コウモリが 超音波までキャッチできるのは
コウモリにとっては夜飛ぶのだから それは必要でしょうし
ですから 必要なセンシビリティーはあって
生きてるのですよ ということだと思いますけど
「ですから 人間の場合 例えば 何かを 音を・・・」
ですから とにかくその質問
質問ではなくて 意見が成り立つのは
「生、生きることは最高だ」 という固定概念がある限りなのです
私にとっては 「生」というのは最高だと
どうやって決めるかという
そういうのは 固定概念で
センシビリティーが 変わっちゃうのですね
仏教は「生」ではなくて 「解脱」ということを言ってるのだから
センシビリティーは足りませんと
今の論理を取ってみても
「今 我々が持ってるセンシビリティーで
うまく生きているのだよ」 ということは
うまく生きるためには センシビリティーが必要なのですね
では センシビリティーが鋭くなったら？
もっとうまく生きていられるでしょう
では センシビリティーが 完全に完成したら？
完成になるでしょう
ですから 別に問題ないと思いますけど
ですから 私のポイントは
センシビリティーは足りませんと
付いてるもので 我々は満足してるのだけど
それ自体が 無知で鈍感だよと
イノシシの音が 聞こえるぐらいの音に 反応するミミズが
イノシシに食われるでしょう 結局は
アリは随分敏感ですけど アリクイがいるのですね
あの動物に 全部片っ端から食べられちゃうし
人間が生きるために センシビリティを持ってるのだけど
事故を起こしてしまうと いろんなことで殺されちゃうし
人が見たら この人はやばいとわかるのだけど
やっぱり殺されちゃうでしょう
結局持ってるセンシビリティでは ろくな結果がないのです
なんとかガタガタ生きてるだけ
ですから苦しみは消えないのです
人間の世界でも戦争は絶えないし
憎しみが絶えないし
苦しみが絶えないし
ずっとあるでしょう
動物の世界でもそうでしょう
動物は鋭い感覚を持ってるのだけど
絶滅状態になっているでしょう
ですから 足らないのですね 結局は
ですからセンシビリティということは
これぐらいの 鈍感なセンシビリティで なんとか生きてるのですから
もう少し センシビリティがあれば どうでしょうか？
「そこで 長老がおっしゃった中で
例えば 物を見るという時に合成して
束にして見ていたと
ただ 十分に 瞑想ですか 修練を積めば
その束の瞬間をずっと縮めていって
一瞬にして 物を見るというか
ちょっとわかりませんけども
私が物を見ているという 物の姿ではなくて
ある一瞬に何を見るのですか？」
その時は何も成り立ちません
私も成り立ちませんし
世界も成り立ちません
ですからすべて崩れるのです
幻想の世界が
そこで初めて真理の世界で
そこで初めて無常が出てくるのです
無常と無執着というのは
それは悟りの世界でありますから
人間の知識では もう理解できるということは 成り立ちません
「普段ものを見ている時に
物のある一点だけを見るとか そんな次元の話ではないわけですね？
話が違う感じがわかりました」
「では よろしいですか？」
「時間の方も ちょっと 参りましたので
ここで一回 回向の文で終了したいと思います」
「では 皆さんで 回向の文」
「仏法僧の三宝に 礼拝 帰依し 戒を守り
慈悲の瞑想と ヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族 恩師をはじめとし
一切の生きとし生けるものに 回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように」
Sabbītiyo vivajjantu sabba rogo vinassatu Mā no bhavatvantarāyo sukhī dīghāyuko bhava.
Bhavatu sabba maṅgalaṃ rakkhantu sabba devata
Sabba buddhānubhāvena
Sabba dhammānubhāvena
Sabba saṅghānubhāvena sadā sotthī bhavantu no.
Abhivādana-sīlissa niccaṃ vuḍḍhāpacāyino,
cattāro dhammā vaḍḍhanti: āyu vaṇṇo sukhaṃ balaṃ.
では　どうもありがとうございました